Spring Break.
Today, I had another fight with my parents.
It seems lately the fights are getting more frequent and more serious.
Sometimes, I really don't get my parents.
Actually, pretty much all the time I don't get my parents.
They're always trying to control me.
Don't they know that I am my own person?
You'd think they were never kids themselves.
I'm practically an adult anyway.
Next week is my 17th birthday.
This time, the fight was over spring break.
It's my junior year of high school,...
...and me and my friends want to go to Rio de Janeiro.
The fight started when my father walked past my room...
...and happened to see me trying on my new bathing suit.
He freaked out!
He said, "I forbid you to wear that outside the house!"...
..."Take it off and bring it back to the store!"
Then he asked me why I was buying bathing suits anyway,...
...and I told him me and my friends are going to Rio for spring break, and his face turned purple!
He said "I order you not to go!"...
..."And that's final."
So there it is, I can't go to Rio when all my friends will be going.
I'll be stuck here all by myself in this crappy town...
...in this crappy house with my crappy parents!